[Música]
bienvenidos a reporteros el magazine de
los grandes reportajes de la redacción
de france 24
soy herminia fernández comenzamos
y transnistria es una pequeña región
separatista de moldavia en la frontera
suroeste de ucrania los países
occidentales sospechan que esta región
actúa como una base de retaguardia para
el ejército ruso el enclave separatista
que ha reclamado su independencia desde
la caída de la unión soviética está
ubicado cerca de la estratégica ciudad
portuaria ucraniana de odessa en el mar
negro nuestra reportera del aura de bq
obtuvo un exclusivo acceso a
transnistria que por ahora se niega a
participar en el conflicto en ucrania y
descubrió una tierra cuya población se
debate entre el apego moscú y las raíces
geográficas europeas aquí la historia
[Música]
vengan chicos vamos al tanque
es un circuito turístico como ninguno
para un país como ningún otro
[Música]
el tanque está colocado aquí desde 1968
desde 2011 andréis smolensk y organiza
tours soviéticos para los pocos turistas
que llegan a transnistria
ahora aprendiendo un poco sobre sobre el
sitio que queremos variar sabemos las
cuatro cosas que encuentras en internet
que si ese país que no existe
transnistria este pequeño enclave
separatista situado entre moldavia y
ucrania declaró su independencia en 1990
a pesar de sus numerosas peticiones
nunca ha sido reconocida por la
comunidad internacional sin embargo
funciona como un estado
d
aquí puedes ver el parlamento y la sede
del gobierno que data de 1983
estatua de lenin de
1987 la bandera de transnistria y la
bandera de rusia
cruzar la frontera ves gente
digamos que técnicamente iguales pero
con otro idioma otro sentido de vida
en cierto
que si se ve esa
aquí la vida parece estar congelada en
el pasado soviético en las grandes
ciudades los restos de la unión
soviética son visibles en cada esquina
para los 470 mil habitantes de habla
rusa del país la historia ocupa un lugar
muy especial
más allá de la lucha contra la alemania
nazi fue sobre todo la guerra
separatista con moldavia en 1992 la que
dejó su huella un conflicto de pocas
semanas pero con varios miles de muertos
que se ahorran cada año en esta plaza
[Música]
la seguridad de transnistria sigue
estando garantizada por 1500 soldados
rusos
pero el pequeño estado sigue intentando
existir por si mismo
[Música]
el territorio comercia con todo el mundo
pero todos los productos deben ser
etiquetados como moldavos y no de
transnistria
una injusticia según vital e ignátiev el
ministro de asuntos exteriores
y
actualmente moldavia bloquea el
suministro de medicamentos alimentos y
fertilizantes a nuestros productores
agrícolas son elementos del bloqueo y el
principal obstáculo que nos impide es
vivir y desarrollarnos libremente
a pesar de ser un estado sin existencia
oficial los habitantes han desarrollado
un fuerte sentimiento patriótico
h de 36 años es guardia de seguridad en
un restaurante como muchos vive en un
barrio heredado de la época soviética
aquí viven muchas muchas nacionalidades
rusos moldavos ucranianos búlgaros todos
es una república de muchas
nacionalidades
mamá estamos en casa
y
todas las noches desde el comienzo de la
guerra en ucrania saia se sienta frente
a rossi a uno la primera cadena pública
rusa donde los presentadores muestran
sin ambigüedades su apoyo a la política
de vladimir putin
[Música]
la guerra siempre la guerra en ucrania
si es terrible
todo el mundo tiene parientes conocidos
y amigos cercanos allí así que es un
tema muy conmovedor que sigo
regularmente emoción alimentada las 24
horas del día por los medios de
comunicación oficiales rusos
y
si me preguntan cómo me gustaría que
resolviera el problema me gustaría la
paz la armonía
en la república moldava de transnistria
se independizaran
en el mejor de los casos
formará parte de la federación rusa
yo lo veo así
todo el mundo aquí quiere que la guerra
termine aunque la mayoría de los
transnacionales son pro rusos no todos
han elegido el lado de moscú
vender la segunda ciudad más grande del
país
alexandr es profesor de matemáticas
desde el inicio del conflicto este
opositor a vladimir putin es muy activo
en las redes sociales
[Música]
me gusta mucho este hombre
alexander está transmitiendo información
sobre la guerra en ucrania con un
propósito específico
esta fue una solución tradicional
ciudadela esto
en nuestra región todo el mundo mira
hacia la federación rusa
y
todo el mundo creía y yo también durante
mucho tiempo que rusia nos cuidaba y nos
ayudaba
mucha gente sólo ve los canales de
noticias rusas y tienen una visión del
mundo sesgada
pero mucha gente no quiere aceptar esta
realidad
si lo hicieran su visión del mundo se
derrumbaría
es muy doloroso lo entiendo
kratos y vuelve
y animado
alexander sigue confiado en que su
gobierno encontrará el camino sin
involucrarse en la guerra
otros han perdido esta esperanza y se
plantean huir a lo que consideran la
madre patria
tatiana es profesora de inglés sign up
tiene 46 años y nunca ha dejado su
vecindario
en 1992 siendo un adolescente vio como
los moldavos atacaban desde lo alto de
su edificio
uy
subimos no sé cómo se llama en inglés
no fue solo por una noche
1 luego dos nuevo 3
y vivimos con ese miedo durante tres
meses
tres meses
bombas bombas ni gomas
tatiana no volverá a pasar por esta
pesadilla
strangelove formas y he recibido un
mensaje muy extraño y horrible que tú
traducir
[Música]
hola bastardos algo así mi nombre es
alexander aléxandros
soy un nacionalista moldavo puse bombas
bajo sus escuelas
y voy a enviarles bombas a ustedes
también
saludo a los moldavos y muerte a los
rusos
realidad o ficción este tipo de mensajes
alimentan el miedo de tatiana ha
decidido vender el apartamento familiar
y trasladarse a san petersburgo donde
vive su hija mayor
estas son las últimas cosas que tenemos
que empacar recogemos rápidamente porque
no nos queda tiempo
mira este es el pasaporte de mi madre
sigue siendo válido se puede ver que es
el de la unión soviética- todavía lo
utiliza sólo es válido en transnistria y
moldavia sólo en esos países
somos el último país soviético del mundo
seguimos siendo un país comunista
tatiana está orgullosa de su educación
soviética
su madre galina profesora de francés
se siente traicionada por rusia desde la
invasión a ucrania
wa
se me estoy harta de la guerra siempre
me ha gustado putin lo respetaba lo
consideraba muy inteligente por esa idea
de que el enemigo no está lejos de
nuestras fronteras me mató
no estoy en contra de los rusos
estoy en contra de la muerte
pero son los rusos los que matan la
gente
ciudadanos divididos sobre la
responsabilidad desde el conflicto un
país dividido entre oriente y occidente
transnistria ha sido acusada
recientemente de ser una base de
retaguardia del ejército ruso su
gobierno lo niega hoy el pequeño
territorio se niega a participar en la
guerra pero por cuánto tiempo
un poco después de irnos una declaración
de un general ruso elevó las tensiones
en la región este alto funcionario
expuso claramente las ambiciones de
moscú conquistar todo el sur de ucrania
para que el ejército ruso pueda enlazar
con transnistria
[Música]
unos días después de esta salida
beligerante se produjeron varios
atentados no reivindicados en
transnistria contra un edificio oficial
o torres de radio rusas
[Música]
después de estos acontecimientos
queríamos saber qué había pasado con las
personas que conocimos
saya el guardia de seguridad aún no ha
sido movilizado pero sigue la situación
con cierta preocupación y se prepara
para lo peor
[Música]
bueno si las hostilidades realmente
comienzan tendremos que hacer algo
tenemos un pequeño ejército
nos defenderemos con nuestras propias
fuerzas nos defenderemos mientras
podamos creo que será así esperamos
recibir ayuda de rusia por supuesto ya
veremos me gustaría creer en lo mejor
pero nadie abandonará transnistria los
habitantes no lo aceptarán
tatiana a sus hijos y su madre galina
han abandonado transnistria
[Música]
estoy diluida porque por un lado estamos
muy tristes por haber tenido que dejar
nuestra casa
también estamos muy contentos de haberlo
hecho ya que llevábamos tres días
intentándolo
mientras preparan el gran viaje a rusia
tatiana y su familia se alojan en casa
de unos amigos en el norte de moldavia
sea cual sea el resultado de la guerra
es probable que transnistria y sus
habitantes no controlen su destino una
historia particular desde sus inicios
que seguirá escribiéndose al antojo de
las potencias vecinas y sus intereses
[Música]
hasta aquí reporteros de la semana
recuerde que para ver esta y las
emisiones anteriores puede visitar
nuestro sitio web france24 puntocom
hasta la próxima
[Música]